the unification of Germany in the late
19th century presented a unique problem
for Britain you see the United Kingdom
wanted little to do with mainland Europe
and it's constant infighting it was only
interested in maintaining and growing
its empire by the end of the 19th
century the German Empire was mainland
Europe's most powerful nation its
emperor Vilhelm ii wanted to increase
Germany's power and build its own global
Empire because prestige and also money
to this end there was one small problem
Britain so the head of Germany's Navy
was a man called Admiral Alfred von
Tirpitz who came up with a great idea
let's begin a major naval buildup but
first I should just let you know that
the purpose of the naval buildup was not
to displace the Royal Navy as the
world's foremost sea power Britain had
to use its Navy to defend its global
Empire whereas Germany could concentrate
its entire fleet in the North Sea this
strategy by the way is known as the
fleet in being doctrine whereby the mere
threat of naval action would be enough
to force concessions with the strategy
in place Germany got to building and
rapidly began to expand its Navy and
Britain for the first few years wasn't
too concerned because its strategy
didn't need to change this strategy was
known as the to power standard whereby
Britain would maintain the same number
of capital ships as the next two largest
navies combined Britain didn't really
become concerned until 1900 when Germany
announced another naval buildup the
British government then appointed a man
called Jackie Fisher as the head of the
Royal Navy to face this challenge and
one of the first things he did was
champion a new type of ship one heavily
armed and armoured whose job it was to
sink enemy battleships this new ship was
finished in 1906 and of the HMS
dreadnought so the fact that Britain had
just made every previously built German
battleship redundant wasn't good news
for Tirpitz nor for Imperial Germany
which was spending far too much money in
all of this in the end the Germans
decided to slow down their naval program
and just kidding they started building
dreadnaughts by 1908 the German Navy had
ordered a dreadnaughts whereas the Royal
Navy possessed one and had ordered six
more and naturally this was worrying for
Britain its concerns were made worse
when considering that Germany's allies
austria-hungary in Italy had ordered
another five dreadnaughts between them
thus Britain was left with three options
one spend all of the money and construct
more warships to come to an agreement
with Germany to slow down production or
three do something no British government
ever wanted to do ally with France and
use her dreadnaughts to balance it out
in the end Britain chose all three it
ordered another eleven dreadnaughts
which in turn would be bolstered by
Frances and as for coming to an
agreement Britain had tried for several
years to get the Germans to slow down
but to no avail
it wasn't until 1912 when the cost of
the naval arms race was becoming
problematic that any agreements were
discussed the issue was that Germany
refused to discuss naval disarmament
until Britain had formally entered an
alliance with it in the end it was the
First Lord of the Admiralty Winston
Churchill who created a program which
meant that for every new dreadnought the
Germans ordered Britain would order to
bust German leaders could see that
continuing towards a new dreadnaughts
would be met with a British response
that would in fact increase the gap
between both countries and by 1914 the
naval arms race was at an end with
Britain in possession of nearly twice as
many dreadnoughts as Germany alongside
the dreadnoughts many hundreds of other
ships had also been built in Germany
opted then to turn its attention to you
boats the naval arms race had severely
damaged anglo-german relations and had
push Britain into an alliance with
France and Russia which as we all know
along with numerous other factors laid
the foundations for the First World War
I hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with extra thanks
to these patrons you can see on screen
for their continued support and an extra
special thanks to James Bissonnette
David archaeologists as ARCA Flash Danny
Maloney party-boy Koch coolin Castleman
Rob Waterhouse Chris wicker Gustav Swan
David Silverman Winston Kate woods
Christian checky Maggie packs Kowski
Lexi Schwinn Anthony Beckett
Robert Wetzel Skye Chappell Mike
spinning three plates are on the white
and Michael Reynolds